[MUSIC]
Disneyland is a paradox because
let's be honest it can be miserable.
With long lines, expensive tickets and
kids having meltdowns.
When our family went there a few years
ago my son Cooper later recalled
the experience in our annual holiday card
by recounting episodes of heat stroke and
vomiting.
Followed by a long, silent car ride home.
Yet he concluded his story by stating
quite sincerely, we can't wait to go back.
Why is this?
How come when we look back on things like
family vacations you hardly remember
the sad or stressful moments, and
instead recall the happy ones?
One answer is laughter.
It releases endorphins that
allow us to endure and
even triumph over negative emotions and
pain.
Laughter and the ability to
find humor in bad situations
is what can explain the Disney Paradox.
Laughter helps to make negative
moments fade, but laughter's power,
extends well beyond making
amusement parks tolerable.
Studies show that it can increase
creativity, improve health and
strengthen relationships.
All of which can have a positive
effect in the business world as well.
First let's look how humor
influences creativity.
Psychologist Alice Eisen and
her colleagues asked participants to
watch a short video, and
then solve a classic creativity challenge.
Where people are given a candle,
a box of tacks and some matches, and
then asked to attach the candle
to the wall in such a way
that the wax doesn't drip on the table
below when the candle is lit.
The answer is that you can use the box
containing the tacks to hold the candle.
Half of the participants
watched a neutral video.
The others watched a funny video.
Only 20% of the participants in the
neutral condition solved the problem, but
three quarters of those in
the funny condition did.
It's not that laughter made
the second group smarter.
It's that it allowed them to relax more,
and feel emotionally safer.
Humor loosened up their mind, and
helped them see connections
they previously missed.
Next let's look at health.
In one study Michael Miller and his
colleagues showed a set of participants
two 15 minute movie
segments 48 hours apart.
The first was a scene from the stressful
war movie Saving Private Ryan.
Then two days later a clip from
the humorous comedy Kingpin.
The participants' blood flow was
measured before the study, and
after each viewing session
with dramatic results.
Blood flow decreased by 35%
after the stressful clip, and
increased 22% after the funny one.
Keep this in mind if your objective
is a better immune system.
Finally, let's look at relationships.
Doris Pazini and her colleagues recruited
couples to participate in a study.
They asked some of the couples to
reminisce about times when they
laughed together.
Other couples were asked to
reminisce about sharing memories
that made them feel good
about their relationship.
At the end of the study,
the researchers measured how satisfied
the couples were in their relationship.
The results showed the couples who
recall times when they laughed together
were more satisfied than those who
recalled shared positive memories.
Laughing together made
their hearts grow fonder.
So why is humor so powerful?
One reason is that laughter
releases endorphins which can
increase pain tolerance.
In one study Robin Dunbar and his
colleagues tested the pain threshold of
participants by wrapping their arms
in a tightening blood pressure cuff
until the individual said they
couldn't take it anymore.
Then they showed participants video clips.
Half getting to see something funny,
and the other half a documentary.
Pain tolerance increased by 10% for
the funny viewers.
So humor seems to make us more
creative and healthier, and
it helps us to develop
stronger relationships.
Now this doesn't mean that you should show
clips from your favorite comedy to break
up a tense meeting.
But it does mean that leaders should allow
humor to flourish whenever they can.
Your teams will appreciate it.
They may even say they
can't wait to go back.
[MUSIC]